es posible que a usted oa uno de sus
seres queridos le hayan diagnosticado
cáncer de vejiga este vídeo le ayudará a
saber más sobre el cáncer de vejiga y
cómo afecta a su cuerpo
su vejiga es un órgano hueco y musculoso
almacena la orina producida por los
riñones desde los riñones la orina viaja
a través de tubos llamados uréteres
hasta llegar a la vejiga
desde la vejiga la orina sale de su
cuerpo a través de otro tubo llamado
uretra
el tejido que recubre el interior de la
vejiga se llama eurotel yo o epitelio de
transición
el tipo más frecuente de cáncer de
vejiga llamado carcinoma urotelial o
carcinoma de células transicionales
comienza en esta capa
aquí las células normales se transforman
en células anormales llamadas células
cancerosas con el tiempo estas células
pueden crecer fuera de control y formar
un grupo de células llamado tumor hay
dos tipos de carcinoma urotelial o de
células de transición dependiendo de
cómo crecen un carcinoma papilar crece
hacia el centro hueco de la vejiga
y un carcinoma plano no crece hacia el
centro los tumores planos son mucho
menos frecuentes pero es más probable
que se propague más profundamente en la
pared de la vejiga
el cáncer de vejiga puede presentar los
siguientes síntomas sangre en la orina
la sensación de tener que orinar con
urgencia tener que orinar con más
frecuencia dolor al orinar hacer un
esfuerzo para orinar y dolor de espalda
baja
es importante saber que otros problemas
de salud también pueden causar estos
síntomas la estadificación del cáncer es
el proceso mediante el cual su médico
averigua si su cáncer se ha extendido y
de ser así hasta donde el estadio 0 se
refiere a un carcinoma papilar o un
carcinoma plano in situ que está
presente sólo en la superficie del
recubrimiento interno de su vejiga
esto significa que no se ha propagado a
la pared de la vejiga en el estadio 1 el
tumor ha crecido más profundamente en el
recubrimiento pero no en la capa
muscular en el estadio 2 el tumor ha
invadido la capa muscular
en el estadio 3 el tumor ha atravesado
la capa muscular de la pared de la
vejiga y se puede haber propagado a los
órganos y los ganglios linfáticos
cercanos
finalmente en el estadio 4 el tumor se
ha propagado a cualquiera de los
siguientes la pared de la pelvis o el
abdomen o al menos a un conjunto de
ganglios linfáticos distantes o un
órgano distante como el hígado o los
pulmones
una serie de factores de riesgo pueden
aumentar su riesgo de cáncer de vejiga
el factor de riesgo más importante es el
tabaquismo otros factores de riesgo
incluyen antecedentes personal o
familiar de cáncer de vejiga
exposición a ciertas sustancias químicas
en el lugar de trabajo tratamientos
previos contra el cáncer tales como la
radiación o medicamentos contra el
cáncer y agua potable que contiene altos
niveles de arsénico
al enfrentarse a un diagnóstico de
cáncer de vejiga continúe hablando con
su médico y su equipo de atención del
cáncer